Marvel movies are great but the
characters are usually just a screen
friendly shadow of their ink and paper
origins while some are spot-on
The Avengers movies costumes don't
always do the originals justice here's
how the Avengers should really look
Hawkeye and black widow for the big
screen Clint Barton dropped his pointy
mask and traditional uniform for a
tactical look but in 2012
hot guys comic costume was redesigned to
look more like the film's version and
less like a scaly purple Wolverine both
versions of Hawkeye are master marksman
and former agents of shield but movie
Hawkeye has a secret civilian family
while comics Hawkeye gets around with
romantic relationships with black widow
and Mockingbird aka Bobby Moore's fun
fact Mockingbird later appeared on
agents of shield but in a completely
different relationship on the other hand
after black widows comics outfit
underwent a significant change in
amazing spider-man number 86 she's
barely changed her modern look both
comic book and MCU versions here are the
basics red hair black bodysuit and wrist
mounted weapons they're nearly identical
in the ways that matter despite
appearing in five different movies we
still don't know much about movie Black
Widow
age of Ultron flashbacks revealed a
little of her history specifically her
training to be a Soviet assassin from a
young age she switched sides after
Hawkeye spared her life and has been a
good guy ever since her comic
counterpart has the same broad strokes
including her Soviet training and
defection to America pretty sure that
Natasha has never been Tony Stark's
assistant in the comics though Captain
America and Falcon MCU Captain America
is undeniably classic cap but his
costume often changes subtly like his
shield originally it was simply well
shield-shaped soon it evolved into the
frisbee he flings today in all the ways
that count the MCU is Captain America is
almost completely comic faithful in the
movies caps a patriotic mascot before he
becomes a hero even using the shield
similar to his early comic appearances
in the comics cap goes undercover as a
bumbling private the scent of secret
missions since then comic cap has lost
his powers retained them died undyed and
even thought he was a Hydra agent so
movie caps got plenty to look forward to
in the comics caps longtime partner the
Falcon wears a funky super suit with
enormous red wings and a plunging
neckline resulting in plenty of
unprotected bare chest movie Falcon is a
somewhat more realistic expiratory flow
a set of highly advanced technological
wings not a military man Comics Falcon
is an ex-criminal who was mentally fused
with a falcon by the red skull like
Aquaman but on land Falcon has limited
control over all Birds
if you ever see Falcon hanging around a
pack of ostriches just run it
interestingly it remains to be seen if
we'll ever see Sam Wilson wield the
shield like he did in the comics in 2014
for Thor's first appearance in 1962
future the largest helmet wings you've
ever seen and kneepads that I make a
goalie blush movie Thor occasionally
wears the helmet and makes the practical
choice to cover his arms and armor and
that beard Comics Odinson generally
prefers a clean shave interestingly the
movies largely ignore Thor's one-time
alter-ego Donald Blake originally Thor
suffered amnesia and was trapped in the
body of a disabled doctor for years
before accidentally rediscovering his
hammer he also fell for nurse Jane
Foster who is obviously a far cry from
the MCU storm chasing Jane and fat
picked up a recent comic book and you'll
be surprised to discover that Jane
Foster is Thor Jane Faust Thor Hey
comics are complicated Scarlet Witch and
Quicksilver the MCU created a less
revealing costume for its Scarlet Witch
in the comics she wears a skimpy body
student a weird headdress fortunately
for Marvel's MPAA rating her on-screen
costume is more autumn fashion
collection than naughty magician's
assistant also kind of different her
powers in the comics she wields chaos
magic while in the movies her abilities
are a lot less defined she basically and
pretty inconsistently changes
probability good for Vegas not always
great at fighting an army of Ultron's
still better than the 90s iron man
animated series Scarlet Witch though
yeesh comics Quicksilver has worn a lot
of costumes ranging from a green with a
lightning bolt all the way to blue with
a lightning bolt the movies cleverly and
subtly incorporated the pattern so this
is another instance where we're glad
they ditched the spandex sure
Quicksilver is really really fast that's
hard to screw up he also started out his
career as a villain before joining the
Avengers not unlike the MC used version
though Comics Quicksilver doesn't die in
his first adventure instead he marries
an inhuman woman and has a full life
let's not even touch ultimate
Quicksilver and his romantic
relationship with his sister let's leave
that for Star Wars shall we vision on
the page visions an Android with a
simple design bright red face green a
yellow costume it's punctuated with the
solar jewel in his forehead movie vision
is distantly more robot-like covered
with mechanical patterns as though the
designers wanted folks to be sure that
this guy's a robot the giant yellow
comics collar gone the biggest
difference is that while vision solar
jewel is powerful in the comics it's
nothing like the Infinity stone his
live-action counterpart wears on the
other head vision and Scarlet Witch are
an item in both the comics and the
movies romance Hulk movie hulk and
comics halt are both big green rage
monster z' but MCU hulk leapfrogged over
his original look
when Bruce Banner first transformed he
was grey Hulk's soon turned green but
occasionally turned gray again switching
wildly between smart and stupid
depending on the color and whatever the
writers wanted to do at that time
comics halt became irradiated during a
heroic act but movie Hulk turns into a
monster because of a failed science
experiment it took years for comics hull
to change from a semi intelligent gray
dude into an incoherent green dude but
hopes film transformation emitted Hulk's
sad decline into madness
he just started out stupid and that
black widow romance you know the one
that came out of nowhere
straight-up movie bunk black panther
prince2 Chawla hasn't changed much
usually just some variation on black
spandex occasionally he makes a mouth
hole and sometimes he rocks a cape
necklace of teeth are gold accoutrements
movie panther is much of the same so far
in the comics what Conda wasn't known to
the US until it traps the Fantastic Four
by the time we meet movie black panther
his country has already set up
diplomatic relations with the rest of
the world
sadly will never see Black Panthers
marriage two x-men storm because those
movie universes just can't touch ant-man
during ant-man's early comic appearances
he had the spandex and underwear look
and his helmet was a huge silver dome
solid sci-fi but bad on the big screen
fortunately the movie heroes outfit
looks much more like a high powered
fight suit while both helmets have an
aunt like appearance the MCU version
nail said there's more than one ant-man
in both the MCU and the comics comics
Hank Pym hung with the original Avengers
and Scott Lang later stole the suit from
him to help his family which should
sound familiar the movies mix-and-match
timelines ant-man and evil corporations
but it's hard to argue with the awesome
results spider-man since debuting in
civil war Spidey's accurate super suit
made fans crazy happy know raised
webbing no energy drink logos just pure
spider-man still MCU Spidey has some
weird half belt what's that about
like most other comic heroes Spidey has
worn roughly a million different
costumes since his first appearance but
its current MCU costume is a totally
fair average of the classic red and
blues war machine and Iron Man also
known as grey Iron Man war machines
always been a variation on Tony's armor
movie war machine is extremely comic
accurate but the iron Patriot's a
different story
an Iron Man 3 Rody's armor gets a
patriotic paint job but in the comics
the iron patriot is actually Norman
Osborn better known as the Green Goblin
Osborn is of course completely insane
and the armor provided an extra layer of
protection from public scrutiny because
how could anyone waving an American flag
possibly be evil movie Iron Man's damn
near perfect even though Tony's changed
armors more times than most people
changed their underwear his films armors
are really comic accurate and under the
armor Robert Downey jr. was born for
that role still the cocky billionaire
from the movies is a caveman compared to
comic book Tony who was recently flying
around in his bleeding-edge armor which
is conveniently stored inside his body
he's not gross at all kind of makes that
armored suitcase and Iron Man to look
like a pile of fancy trash thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know which is your favorite
Marvel costume